I have a dream that's all I need
[Music]
I'll pay mistakes but mistakes make you
strong hey what's up guys in this video
I'm gonna give you seven tips to
increase your tester on levels naturally
why is it important to keep your tester
on levels high well to testerone is very
important for your overall health and
well-being if you have low testosterone
levels you might experience low
self-esteem lack of energy low sex drive
depression weight gain moodiness thinner
bones and thinner hair now to test your
own is that hormone that helps us to go
through puberty you know get that little
bit stronger voice help us to grow hair
in a lot of areas you know to become a
man but as we get older the testerone
goes down it declines now most people
believe that it is only important for
guys I guess what it also plays a role
in the health and sexual well-being of
women all right so how do you increase
your testosterone levels well let's
start with the first one get enough
sleep if you don't sleep enough your
contester levels drop study from the
University of Chicago showed that even
if you get five hours of sleep you will
still have 15% lower the testerone than
if you slept around seven or eight hours
lose weight research shows that obese
men have lower to testerone levels how
much lower well one study in the journal
Clinical Endocrinology showed that some
of these men have up to 50% less the
testerone than men who are not
overweight on the other side if your
body fat percentage is too low it's not
good either because it also causes you
to have lower the testerone so just be
healthy not to fact not to then can I
say that exercise and lifting weights
working out a few days a week is very
very good for you in so many ways that
you're not even aware of like preventing
many lifestyle diseases but it is also
good for boosting your to tester on
resistance training is the best type of
exercise to booster to test your own for
not only the short term but also for the
long term and taking caffeine before
you're working out can also boost it
even more as one of the reasons why I
love coffee so much vitamins and
supplements now study showed that
vitamin D and also zing boost your to
test your own the most so get in the Sun
more for that vitamin D or you can also
get the natural vitamin D from naught E
and the zinc from garden of life like
always have added the direct links for
you in a video description down below so
you can go and check it out maintain a
balanced diet your testosterone levels
also depends a lot on what you are
eating
if you overeat or constantly change your
diet plan it can disrupt your
testosterone levels you don't want that
so you need to maintain a healthy diet
of protein fat and carbs it'll keep your
cholesterol level is high and also
improve your long-term health
try to minimize your stress levels Lam
stress influences so many things of your
body especially your to test your own
levels stress causes your hormone
cortisol to raise and when that happens
your detector on level lowers so when
the one goes up the other one goes down
and vice versa this is very important
because most people today have a lot of
stress and studies show that 44% people
say that over the last five years their
stress increased a lot the biggest
reason why you might stress so much is
because you are worrying constantly
about things that you cannot control you
need to let go remember one of the
strongest weapons against stress is your
ability to choose one thought over
another the next step is very important
so listen up especially you young guys
out there stop using drugs and alcohol
ah Daniel but it's so cool it's so fun
is it really it also destroys millions
of lives and it tears up families
[Music]
I know from personal experience because
my brother used to sell drugs and it
cost him his life
my uncle used to drink a lot and he was
a bum on the street and there was
nothing we can do for him I used to
drink a lot myself when I was younger I
stopped and it changed my life now does
it lower your taxes rone yes of course
it does according to studies the
National Institute of Alcohol Abuse and
Alcoholism it affects that the lands of
hormones involved in male reproductive
health and it lowers the testerone by
its effect on your body causing hormonal
reactions and cell damage now if you're
new here on my channel check out one of
these videos you might like it you might
find it interesting if you liked this
one give it a thumbs up subscribe and we
will talk soon Cheers